I wonder if they like twisting the knife
a little bit they're like what if the
other guy has a huge dick and you're
like wait what what the [ __ ] is
[Music]
all right this is this is gonna be a
good one because uh Min had a good video
about what to do in this situation
uh the third biggest lottery jackpot was
just awarded in Illinois
1.34 billion whoa whoa
a billion Oh Billy that's not even
that's not even funny anymore that's
just ridiculous how much do they get to
leave with after taxes well it's going
to be split between two people because
two people want it how the [ __ ] they get
the same number and that means each
person is only going to take home like a
quarter million a quarter billion 250 or
something like that are they both in
Illinois or only one uh yeah they're
both in Illinois dude that's right do
they got state taxes like we do or no do
they only have to pay federal they got
federal state they have federal and
state yeah so if you take a look so you
take a lump sum right now you get less
than you can do it over yeah 30 years
but the thing is in 30 years if they
keep raising taxes it gets diminished
anyway so you either pay as well always
go for the love
I think that's the biggest thing is like
not to tell anybody oh yeah that's they
definitely did that thing where like so
I don't know if it's the same in
Illinois but I know it is in California
if you win the lotto and you don't want
anyone to know that it was you you have
to give up some of that money to buy
that anonymity son's a [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] how much I don't know I really
don't know what it is it's worth it but
God if you have a big family yes the
[ __ ] Lotto Mafia well that's probably
the first good thing to spend that money
on yeah that's true so they're splitting
the money uh it's they chose to do the
lump sum it says they're they're
choosing the lump sum payment I don't
know if it's correct 780 million each
wow is that the right math 1.3 that's
almost like 700 million each yeah 780
million each yeah yeah you're probably
walking with 700 so probably like 300.
hey yeah that's still right that's
pretty good yeah they take 400 from you
God when you do when you do the lump sum
they take more than just way more yeah
but then if that's better because if you
do the payments then you know they're
not going to send an assassin to kill
you and cut the payments shortly sure
true so what was it that you said you
had a thing on your socials about what
you would do and it was pretty [ __ ]
smart because yours was really good it
was mainly about uh not paying tax on
pretty much the money that you you earn
yeah so I would I would go out there
first like get a lawyer get a lawyer
first and then take that money and find
a way to put it into more properties and
then when you put in the property put in
the trust where if you put in enough
trust pretty much you're not paying
taxes on the gain yeah if you're in the
trust or if you put it into your raw
your retirement you don't have to pay
taxes on the game so it's about capital
gains what if what if um are you so like
do they give you the check first and
then they're subject to tax after or is
it like a paycheck where they remove the
tax first and then they give you the
remainder that I don't know but rather
than just having to take the tax on the
spot yeah you know I think they take the
tax out and they give you the remainder
do they give you one of those big ass
checks I hope so right that these guys
like trying to be anonymous and like
walking into the bank because I'm
wondering if okay so like if like let's
say I own the Red Cross that's my
organization nice what if I won the
lotto and I go yeah I'm gonna take the
whole thing and just donate it then
would they be able to but then you up
your salary
oh but they know that you are the Red
Cross you're donating to something
exactly so like because you know when
you when you make earnings right but if
you give it all away they can't tax you
on that to a non-profit yeah because
it's like you didn't you didn't take any
of that I think I think they're already
taking the taxes out when they give you
the money though yeah you don't get it
yeah right away so you were saying that
it's better to um let's say you got all
that money rather than put it in stocks
and those stocks do well you have to pay
Capital Gains if you put it in real
estate what happens if you're the
properties go up in value that you if
they if they go up in value you just sit
on it unless you want to transfer the
property out so you're just sitting on
the property and just gaining Equity
you're not really paying tax on the
equity and then you keep transitioning
up and up and up and then of course if
you do want to sell it you sell off a
portion and you can slow down how you
get taxed on that money too so there's
all different ways to with real estate
because of the the way it's so the state
of Cal or the United States is built on
um tax law you know tax laws are built
on real estate and being an entrepreneur
so if you can either pay less tax or
slow down the way you get paid taxes and
there's a bunch of ways to do that if
you put it in property correct you can't
do it and you can't do it in um you
can't do it in day trading you can't do
it in any business because you're going
to have to unless unless you completely
wipe it all out and then you get audited
so the safest way where you're not going
to get audited is to keep flipping in
real estate and that's mainly because uh
the government gives you tax incentives
for Real Estate because in that sector
right
um the government is being measured in
their success and growth of the economy
by things like real estate they want to
give tax breaks to people to buy land or
buy property or to build property
because that shows that their growth as
a country as a nation as an economy is
getting better so they're giving you tax
benefits which end up making people want
to roll their money into things like
those sectors so let's say you come
across 300 million let's say this was
you what would you do with that money
split it with JK yeah sounds a good plan
I would buy as much real estate as I can
and then find a make sure I do the math
on uh depreciation and cost segregation
so when I collect the rent money I don't
have to pay any taxes on that red money
you'll stick to residential uh
commercial commercial because you you
can stretch out the depreciation you get
miles and stuff so let's but let's ask
the hard questions let's say you don't
pay for the anonymity what do you say to
all the aunties and uncles and cousins
yeah dude because that's the real thing
that nobody prepares you for man I got
school loans man I break off everybody I
would do it must have been Asian coming
here like you know what let me before I
die let me wipe it out for everybody
everyone gets a fresh start but you know
a lot of people that come back after the
and they're dumb too you give them like
10 G's for a car or whatever ah [ __ ]
up man [ __ ] smoke crack gone now
you buy them a property under their name
yeah and that you put in you put a trust
where like they can't sell the property
but the rental income keeps going back
to them and then just Fork out the
depreciation
right okay when they receive that rent
it's the depreciation and cost
segregation already washes the rent
money can you can you can you explain
like for the idiots that don't
understand what a trust is yeah not us
yeah yeah tell them what the trust is
trust is like another vehicle instead of
like you owning it directly it's owned
by another entity it's like a vault that
no one can touch okay and then you also
can make the rules in the trust where
you can assign it to somebody or it can
almost live forever
live forever so so let's say you you
have a trust that could go to your great
great grandson the trust will keep going
you want it to keep going if you're like
hey you can't it's an irrevocable trust
like hey you let's say you have that
crackhead cousin or uncle that you were
you know you buy that property you put
in the trust hey they're always receive
money but if you pass away they can't oh
they're probably gonna change who's
living and they can go they can ruin
your whole like Legacy correct and sell
it all for crack yes
but then with the trust that protects
the crack yeah
yeah so uh what are the tax benefits of
like making that kind of a move like
trust
um I'm not a tax person so I'm not
supposed to give you like exact uh
direction we are benefits so you know
first I think when you receive some sort
of money you have to decide okay what do
you want to get taxed on and what you
don't want to get taxed on so depending
on the business let's say you receive
money as a business if you want to avoid
tax on it you gotta do something with it
right away and then that's when you
decide okay if I want these businesses
how do I put them in llc's do I put
these llc's in trust you know you got to
kind of Juggle it around but if you keep
juggling around enough which a lot of
people do you start deteriorating your
actual income that's why you see these
guys from uh you know Rich Dad Poor Dad
yeah um none of them own anything they
own nothing in their name it's all owned
under llc's that are put in trust that's
like you know so it's like a juggling
act to pretty much diminish your income
and you're just living off of loans oh
God but you're asking but your trust and
your LLC like it's worth so much like
you know very make America's gonna break
you off and loan you the money right but
you're only paying taxes on the stuff
that's in your name correct
so the um
so after all
trusts have been around there's no way
to like work around that let's say like
somebody left you a trust and they died
there's absolutely no way for you to
kind of skirt around and get all of it
depends if it's a revocable or
irrevocable living trust so if you know
you're the person like oh I know he's a
crackhead there's no way I'm doing a you
know
revocable you know irrevocable living
trust you know or revocable living trust
damn those things are really bulletproof
huh
you can't change any rules when you even
you made the rules but all of a sudden
you get older and you become senile and
people start coming up to you like all
right I'll give this to you if it's
irrevocable there's nothing like I would
have thought by now some rich kid would
have figured out a crazy ass loophole
together but that's the thing with like
like wills and like trusts and stuff
they they're set so that
um your support the the whole like point
of it is in your best state of mind you
are agreeing to this contract so that in
a lesser state of mind you don't go back
and change things and you can create
different stipulations too like it's
like this will go to my son if he gets a
college degree it will go to my daughter
if she becomes a doctor or whatever
otherwise it'll all be donated to this
cause yup wow people could do that like
there's like many steps that you can
because people could be like
um like let's say oh this will have
hella money like hey go back in there
change your [ __ ] living trust you
know but then you can't like it's
irrevocable I literally can't change it
anymore does it normally cost a lot of
money to have a trust exist you go on
[ __ ] Legal Zoom bro it was me I'd
probably go to someone and just pay like
the 20 right now we have one for my son
it's we paid 2 500 bucks and then we got
it done but you when you get go you go
get a trust with their spouse do they
ask you some [ __ ] [ __ ] up question
like like if you die who's who are your
kids gonna live with everyone oh and
then you really gotta like hit or like
or if you die and your wife remarries
does that kid gets any of the money in
the trust and you're like nah like
there's some things
that's really what happens yeah they ask
like who's gonna get your kid they're
all desensitized to it too they say this
[ __ ] all the time
because I think like when you have a you
know husband and wife everyone thinks
their kids should go live with their
side of the family that's when it gets
like awkwardly quiet you know things
that you don't think about like if you
go get a trust go with go see a
counselor or go get married therapy
first before you go because they're
gonna ask you some things that you can
bring you I wonder if they like twisting
the knife a little bit they're like what
if the other guy has a huge dick and
you're like wait what what the [ __ ] it
was even like the the very first time we
we llc'd up uh kinjas yeah right uh I
remember me Michael and sitting with the
lawyer and stuff like that and then they
you know they never like llc'd like a
dance group so the closest thing they
could do was show us an example of an
operating agreement for a rock band
where all the different members like
kind of like I'll have a some sort of uh
Equity or entity in in this like larger
brand of a group that's built on people
right and so all the questionnaires and
stuff it's kind of like uh just like a
rock band it's like all right if this
person like decides to leave the group
but you know you're like super naive
even at first state of mind when you're
starting a business so you're just like
wow how would anybody leave like you
know what I mean like but but it just
asks you and puts you in this position
of like real life situations that have
already happened it's like this person
leaves decides to sue you and blah blah
blah like and you're just kind of like
uh met with this reality of what
actually happens and suddenly you have
to make like these grown-ass decisions
that you've never had to face before you
know what I mean that's good that you
made it so no one's allowed to leave
that's what you got to give you that you
got to get your papers right right away
you know especially I think it's hard uh
when it when money isn't when there's no
money in the picture yet oh everyone's
like dude we're gonna split it all oh
yeah and then eventually money's not
trickling as I then I just do more work
for this [ __ ] he just flew in
and then I gotta do everything and now I
gotta split the [ __ ] that's some amateur
[ __ ] though in the very beginning
everybody fights over this stuff that's
my [ __ ] dude that's just life in general
that that's every [ __ ] organization
right things change people change work
changes scale changes [ __ ] terrible
ideas it's completely stupid but it's
fun in the beginning and then later you
learn yeah it's legendary in the
beginning you learn the difference
between businesses and and homie [ __ ]
yeah
foreign
[Music]